[Music]
on this Wednesday night pushing for
answers there has never been information
more questions about alleged Chinese
interference in Canadian democracy
Alberta's proposed power play over
Ottawa the red flags about Premier
Danielle Smith's sovereignty Act
Nightmare on Metro Vancouver streets
the mess misery and Mayhem I was stuck
in the car more than eight and a half
hour and on the move for months a quest
to Corral some runaway cows in Quebec
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us prime
minister Justin Trudeau faced more
questions today about alleged Chinese
interference in Canada's Democratic
process the question started following a
story Global News broke earlier this
month sources have told Global
intelligence officials briefed the prime
minister in January about China
allegedly targeting Canada including
funding a network that sent money to 11
Federal candidates during the 2019
election all of it done to advance
beijing's political agenda the RCMP said
this week it is investigating foreign
interference activities in Canada but
the extent of that interference and who
is made aware of it is still unclear
Mackenzie gray has our top story tonight
out of the honorable leader of the
opposition for the second day in a row
the questions kept coming was there any
interference to his knowledge yes or no
I have not in all the briefings I've
received there has never been
information around candidates receiving
money from China another push from the
opposition to find out what the Prime
Minister knew about alleged interference
in the 2019 election Trudeau again
denying ceases told him the names of the
11 candidates allegedly funded by China
through a sophisticated scheme to
influence that election but Global News
is not reported cesus briefed him on the
identities of those candidates who
received nearly a quarter million
dollars in donations another common
refrain from Trudeau we created an
independent panel to evaluate foreign
interference threats to Canadian
elections that confirms the election
integrity was not compromised but the
alleged interference wasn't flagged by
ceases to Trudeau until January 2022
according to sources well after the
report looking into the 2019 election
was published that timeline was backed
up yesterday by the RCMP commissioner
Brenda lucky wrote to the procedure and
house Affairs committee which is
studying the alleged interference she
said the mounties didn't have any
evidence of alleged interference during
the 2019 campaign but are now probing
interference and Democratic processes a
former thesis director says the spy
agency would have quickly shared
information like alleged interference
with the Prime Minister and likely tried
to cooperate it with other security
organizations well I think the first
thing I would do is to try and find out
whether this view was shared by the RCMP
whether the chief electoral officer was
concerned or not experts like dick
Fadden have called on the liberal
government to put in new measures to
make sure that foreign interference
doesn't happen in the next election but
in the indo-pacific strategy the
Liberals just announced they didn't put
in any new measures to deal with that
Donna all right Mackenzie the Prime
Minister has been taking a tougher
stance on China lately he made some
remarks to Reuters news today what did
he say well some really strong remarks
he looked to take a swipe at China's
covet 0 policy and how they're handling
those protests let's take a listen
China is an increasingly important
global economic power but it's also an
increasingly challenging or disruptive
global economic power and we have to be
thoughtful about how we engage while at
the same time being consistent that
we're going to stand up for our values
for our principles for uh the things
that our citizens in the west expect us
to to stand for not just for our own
purposes but to highlight to people in
China who disagree with the regime that
there are other ways of doing things and
there is a a better future so some
strong words from Justin Trudeau there
we asked uh the former Canadian
Ambassador China what he thought about
that he agreed that this is some of the
strongest talkies heard from Justin
Trudeau since being elected in 2015.
he's saying though that issues of
democracy Canada should be standing up
but you should expect that there should
be some pushback from Beijing at some
point in time and it's really been all
us on Asia recently Donna for Justin
Trudeau he's been going to Asia recently
a big trip they are into Pacific
strategy announced a 2.3 billion dollars
there and the point of that strategy is
to try to kind of isolate China make
other friends in the region but Donna it
actually could be China isolating Canada
after comments like this just like Xi
Jinping threatened Justin Trudeau he
would do at the G20 all right Mackenzie
gray and Ottawa thank you there has been
a lot of reaction to it Alberta Premier
Danielle Smith unveiled yesterday the
proposed legislation is called the
sovereignty act within a United Canada
Smith says it will be a constitutional
shield to protect albertans from federal
overreach critics say if there's any
overreach It Is by Smith herself that
the ACT would give Smith and her cabinet
extraordinary powers to bypass the
legislature our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson is following this
Mercedes why is Smith's sovereignty act
raising red flags what's in it well
Donna despite the name it actually has
nothing to do with Alberta separation
but it does introduce some pretty
significant and exceptional powers for
her government the sovereignty act would
allow the province to direct police and
government agencies to disregard federal
laws that it deems harmful by the
Alberta legislature but the ACT doesn't
really say what harm means it could be
used though for example against things
like implementing gun legislation or as
Premier Smith noted the emergencies act
and while that rhetoric on all of this
is around targeting Ottawa the reality
is that it gives Premier Smith and her
cabinet tremendous Powers allowing them
to unilaterally override the Alberta
legislature and rewrite bills without
putting those bills back in front of
mlas for a vote constitutional law
expert Eric Adams says this kind of
change is unprecedented
I'm not comfortable with the executive
possessing that power outside of some
very rare circumstances like say an
emergency where time is of the essence
there's really no justification that I
can see that would justify the executive
uh possessing that power under this bill
the bill has created fractures inside
Alberta's UCP and among Federal
conservatives too former Premier Jason
Kenney has called it nuts in the past
and last night he sent a clear message
resigning as an MLA saying he is quote
concerned that our Democratic life is
veering away from ordinary Prudential
debate towards a polarization that
undermines our Bedrock institutions and
principles Donna there are questions
about whether this law is constitutional
it of course has not yet been tested in
front of the courts to see whether a
premiering cabinet can in fact overrule
a legislature and simply rewrite bills
and Mercedes the point of the ACT
obviously to to stand up to Ottawa what
is the federal government's response
today
well Justin Trudeau isn't committing to
challenging the act and he also isn't
condoning it he's likely trying to avoid
antagonizing the large number of
albertans who might really not like his
government but also might not be big
fans of Danielle Smith here's what he
had to say about it today
we're going to see how this plays out
I'm not going to take anything off the
table but I'm also not looking for a
fight we want to continue to be there to
deliver for albertans there's going to
be things that we agree with that
government on there's kind of things we
disagree with them on and my focus is
always going to be to be constructive in
terms of delivering for people right
across the country
at the end of the day this isn't about
Justin Trudeau's political future it's
about Danielle Smith's she's the one who
will have to face the electorate in
Alberta in May Donna all right Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thank you well it is
late November and it has snowed in many
places which is hardly news in this
country except on the west coast when
snow often seems to snarl things
and it did again last night most areas
had less than 10 centimeters of snow but
as need through garcha reports with the
temperature hovering right around
freezing it didn't take much to turn the
roads into a big slippery mess trapping
some drivers in traffic for hours
uh oh here comes another one with Metro
Vancouver's first major pileup of snow
came pileups of vehicles there we go
as well as a fair share of frustration
and fear of the treacherous conditions
some drivers in BC's Lower Mainland
region unprepared for the forecasted
snowstorm hitting hard during the busy
evening commute
and even many who had come equipped
became stranded into the early hours of
the morning I was I was the car more
than 8.5 and a half hour I do have smoke
no food no drink yeah and uh
I mean it's really disaster I can say
that even at midnight roads resembled
rush hour after strong winds and blowing
snow swept across BC's South Coast
typically short drives turned into big
trouble hours-long Odysseys back to the
burbs I got home at 4 a.m an eight hour
commute home
thousands woke up without power
Wednesday most of the nearly 90 000 BC
Hydro customers had electricity restored
by midday but Crews were unable to reach
some regions on Vancouver Island because
of mass Ferry cancellations air travel
also affected with flight cancellations
and a passenger jet sliding off a
taxiway of Vancouver International
Airport we had a little bit of snow
in a first world country a G7 country
and we cannot handle it some drivers
expressed their anger about uncleared
roads and Transit shutdowns as they
scrambled to help each other create both
paths out of the snow and friendly
reminders to plan ahead
some kids jumping at the chance to enjoy
a snow day with many classes canceled
the province's hills and mountainous
terrain providing unique but familiar
winter challenges and while weather
warnings are still in effect in higher
elevations away from the water these
conditions are expected to taper off
into rain overnight
Global News Burnaby BC
the European Union will create a
specialized Court to investigate and
prosecute possible war crimes by Russia
since the Russian invasion began in
February thousands of ukrainians have
been killed in one example in a key
suburb there remains more than 450
people have been recovered many bodies
showing signs of torture the EU also
wants to use frozen Russian Financial
assets to pay for the estimated 830
billion dollars in war damage in Ukraine
and Russia's State nuclear energy
company says a Ukrainian engineer has
now been appointed to head the nuclear
power plant in zapparesia the facility
seized by Russia in March is heavily
damaged it hasn't been producing
electricity since September it is being
run by Ukrainian workers to help keep it
safe Ukraine claims Russia has tried to
coerce employees into signing contracts
that sever ties with Kiev in October the
plant's former director General was
detained for days before being released
to preserve and protect coming up the
indigenous lead initiatives finding
success in conserving biodiversity
indigenous peoples ties to the land go
back thousands of years and now efforts
are underway to better recognize that
connection next week the International
Community gathers in Montreal for the
U.N biodiversity conference in Canada
indigenous nations are taking the lead
nearly 90 percent of protected areas
created over the past two decades have
been led by indigenous Nations many more
have been proposed Eric Sorensen
explains why their approach works and
what indigenous groups hope will come
out of the cop-15 conference
it is a shocking statistic the loss of
biodiversity on the planet could put up
to one million species at risk of
Extinction one way it's being addressed
is this indigenous Guardians on the land
learning and Reporting in areas like
British Columbia's Central Coast to
protect species such as salmon I'm happy
to see this but historically there was a
lot more next week when cop 15 the UN
convention on biological diversity comes
to Montreal indigenous nations from
around the world will promote new
Partnerships to lead the way in
sustaining lands while respecting
indigenous rights protecting healthy
lands Waters plants animals it also
supports our cultures and our way of
life and our knowledge systems and our
communities well-being the United
Nations cop 15 goal is 30 by 30 protect
30 percent of the land and Oceans by
2030. Canada is about halfway there from
Yukon and Northern British Columbia and
across all provinces and territories
Ottawa is funding indigenous-led
initiatives to protect biodiversity one
region is the seal River Watershed
indigenous protected area in Northern
Manitoba The Watershed is pristine and a
storehouse for two billion tons of
carbon the indigenous people who've
lived in the region for Generations are
becoming the recognized stewards of the
land we understand that
this work we're doing it's a process in
respecting our vision for the Watershed
respecting our voices we are working
together to protect this land for our
future for our children's children for
Canadians for people around the world in
all more than two dozen indigenous
protected areas could see more than half
a million square kilometers conserved
across the country I have faith that the
country of Canada will continue down
this path of increasing its conservation
in Montreal police are also preparing
for cop 15 and potential disruption from
protesters unhappy with the influence of
industrial interests at the summit but
inside the aim will be to find agreement
among governments indigenous Nations and
others to slow and ultimately stop the
loss of the world's biodiversity Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
paging out ahead concern as many workers
approach retirement
[Music]
[Music]
my son lost for music fans Christine
McVie who played with Fleetwood Mac and
wrote some of their most famous songs
has died at the age of 79. McPhee joined
the band In 1970 she wrote some of their
biggest hits including little lies and
you make loving fun her band mates are
remembering her today as talented beyond
measure her family says McPhee died
following a short illness
there is a new snapshot of Canada's
Workforce thanks to the latest stats
Canada data among people aged 25 to 64
more than 57 percent have a university
or college degree Canada has led G7
countries in this category since 2006.
statscan says the country's strong
post-secondary education system is key
nearly a quarter of Canadians hold a
college certificate diploma or similar
credential as Marty blunt reports all
that education is great but Canada's
Workforce is still aging at a rate
that's concerning
business is shifting into high gear at
this Winnipeg Auto Body Shop Collision
for winter picked up as soon as the
first snowfall hit but the wait time for
customers to get their car back on the
road is lengthy it's probably due to
technician shortage to be honest with
you not enough people in the trade
anymore
according to the latest Census Data it's
not the only industry feeling the pinch
the number of working age people in the
trades industry has either fallen or
remained flat with mechanic and repair
trades dropping nearly eight percent
Precision production dropping 10 percent
and construction trades Rising just
minimally so there's significant
problems that and and every every year
that problem doesn't get better it gets
worse because there's more people
leaving the trades and getting into the
trades this amid record high labor
demand and an increase of the Baby
Boomers aging into retirement the
numbers a stark difference from the
amount of working age Canadians with a
bachelor's degree or higher that Rose
more than 19 percent according to the
census something industry experts say
needs to be addressed at a Grassroots
level instruction is not being presented
as a career of choice high schoolers are
not necessarily getting that balanced
message about what you can do in
construction which can do in trades the
report also indicates trades have been
limited by an underrepresentation of
women immigrants and racialized groups
as well as a high unemployment rate
among immigrants with foreign degrees
something that Canadian construction
Association says needs to be addressed
but until then the lack of laborers
means a service slowdown back in the
shop we're currently booking first week
of January other shops I heard are
booking into March so it's anywhere from
five to eight weeks 12 weeks now it's an
issue that isn't new but likely one that
isn't going anywhere anytime soon
statscan says the trend is expected to
continue over the next decade as more
baby boomers reach retirement now to put
that into perspective in 2021 30 percent
of workers in mechanic or Precision
production trades were over the age of
55. Marty blunt Global News Ottawa
cattle chaos next The Runaway cows
creating headaches for Quebec farmers
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Applause for the baguette the crunchy
quintessentially French bread has been
added to the United Nations cultural
heritage list the country is said to
produce more than 16 million baguettes a
day French president Emmanuel macron
lobbied for this he says the baguette is
key to the French identity and is envied
around the world
while we humans like to think we've got
control over domesticated animals on
farms we keep animals and pens and
surrounded by fences in Quebec it's some
dairy cows that are in control they
broke through fencing and have been on
the loose for months they fled a farm in
Saint Barnaby that's about an hour's
Drive Northeast of Montreal and they
have moved since to the Village of Saint
severe where they have evaded every
attempt to capture them including by
Cowboys on Horseback Mike Armstrong
reports
[Applause]
they are out there somewhere the forests
around the village of Saint Seville
Quebec are home at least for now to a
troop of runaway cows fugitives from
Pierre La pointe's Farm
the point says the story started on a
stormy night in Late July some of his
cows were scared by thunder and
lightning and knocked down a fence 32
escaped although that's a number that's
growing
the point says the cows were almost all
pregnant and some are having babies in
the wild two or three so far
now the cows seem to spend their days in
the forest basically hiding and venture
out at night they are a problem the
farmer who snapped these photos of The
Runaways says they've trampled his
fields and cost him crops one was even
hit by a car local farms are now suing
the cow's owner they've done tens of
thousands of dollars of damage and as
the weather's changed they've started
eating livestock feed at farms this new
hunting cameras made for deer it's
looking for cows just this past weekend
this whole area was set up sort of like
a Corral and several of the animals were
driven almost into it they didn't quite
make it in they escaped again and they
were basically spooked they haven't been
back here since
there have been other attempts to catch
the cows a group of actual Cowboys from
a western Festival came close to getting
them
Villages director General says the cows
were corralled and moving but got away
in a tall cornfield
the hope now is for La pointe's cows to
be captured with traps feed stations are
being set up they put their head in to
eat but can't get their head out there
is however still the question of how to
get them back to LA pointe's Barn
they're becoming more and more wild and
stronger it's not just a matter of
pulling them with a rope
the point says if someone tries that
they're going to be pulled from one end
of a field to the other on their behind
yeah
news of seism else runaway cows has gone
around the globe The Village's director
General admits it's a strange one and
says she'd probably find it funny too if
it was happening somewhere else Mike
Armstrong Global News Quebec
I'm rooting for the cows that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada is Dildo
Newfoundland and Labrador thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]